the views and opinions expressed on this
program are those of the guests
appearing on the program
and do not necessarily reflect the views
and opinions of 8 news now or next our
media group
that issue never came to my office prior
to the legislative session
tonight on politics now we sit down with
governor steve sisselak to go over the
legislative session
that includes the death penalty bill
opportunity zones and the upcoming
gubernatorial race
white house press secretary jensaki
answers our questions about election
reform and changes to the presidential
primary plus
it is a solution in search of a problem
an election reform bill hits a roadblock
in the senate we take a closer look at
what's next
from eight news now this is politics now
thank you for joining us i'm john
langler governor steve sissellach says
not having face-to-face
meetings kept some bills from passing at
the legislative session
this week i sat down with governor
sisolak to talk about the session
and that was a common theme here is part
of that interview and it starts with him
answering a question about the
innovation zones bill
we ran out of time i still think an
innovation zone is a potentially
great idea uh if we need to change
things that are happening in nevada and
we do
we need to change how we're funding
education we need to change the
diversity in the jobs that we have
we need to change you know our forward
thinking i think an innovation offers an
opportunity
we made it into a study where it's going
to be manned by people from the
legislature to sit down and understand
the
intricacies of it it's an important
issue
it deals with a lot of different areas
but you have to address the
tax revenue and the water situation and
the housing costs and the infrastructure
costs
in all of those things and the way the
legislature was going
when it wasn't open to the public and
you couldn't get in and then when people
were allowed to call in for public
comment it was limited to two minutes
and
you know per person and 30 minutes total
it wasn't conducive
to something of this magnitude what
conversations you and your staff had
with the people in story county before
the state of the state because following
that and through the legislative session
at least in my discussions with the
county manager and others up there
they felt completely out of the loop and
obviously they're not happy with the
idea of if this goes forward the way it
was presented initially
it would be self it would be self
autonomous self governing and would be
isolated from essentially story county
well we do the best we can to maintain
communications with all
17 counties and that's just that there's
just one or two of them
there's 17 counties that we try to stay
in contact with
i know that the people that were
advocating for the innovation zones met
with story county
some of the legislators that you
represent those areas
were involved in the discussion and we
had the discussions that we possibly
could now can you ever have enough
discussions
no that's why the problem he had with a
short session when we're only there for
120 days
also with the restrictions related to
covid i couldn't call a meeting where i
had you know
25 people come in for the governor's
office or the capitol and say okay let's
all sit around the table here and talk
about
the benefits of an innovation zone and
what it would provide to the state
there is a death penalty case that will
likely be delayed but it's
you know there's an execution sort of on
the relatively immediate horizon here
how do you feel about the department of
corrections
using experimental drug cocktails for
uh for the death penalty in nevada and
do you
would you like the state to alter what
qualifies
for it even if the death penalty isn't
abolished well
you've got several questions in there i
can't speak as it relates to the
zane floyd case that uh the d.a is
bringing forward because that's under
litigation right now
and that's working its way through the
courts and and hopefully they'll come to
a resolution in terms of how to deal
with it quickly
as it relates to the issue uh that came
before me in carson city or didn't get
to my desk
i was that that issue never came to my
office prior to the legislative session
in terms of trying to understand what
would be a palatable for me in my
administration what we'd accept and what
we wouldn't it came out of the
legislative session and i have some
cases
having gone through one october
personally i am not a strong supporter
of the death penalty being used
as often as it's being used right now
but in the worst of the worst cases
uh like we had at one october i think
that that option should be made
available so we'd have to make some type
of uh
accommodation for concerns but here
again
that is such a groundbreaking issue it's
so crucial people are so passionate
on both sides of that issue that you
need to have
a thorough vetting of that question and
you can't do that when you
have zoom calls and people are limited
to two minutes of conversation
and you can only get 10 or 15 people
into the conversation to voice their
opinion
one of the other issues that was maybe
you would suggest
delayed by zoom calls and so forth is
the ongoing issue with dieter
and unemployment there's been i don't
know
three or four i i forget the number of
people who are
at the head of dieter since the
beginning of the pandemic
um and there are still issues that
people have with getting their
their benefits taken care of um
what needs to be done and what's taking
so long
well dieter is a uh a major problem i
don't think anyone can deny that
but you're finding out across the
country that the estimates are fifty
percent
of the cases that were applied for of
getter benefits were fraudulent
i mean hundreds of millions of dollars
were applied for and money got paid out
on fraudulent claims
and we need to do more in concert with
the attorney general department of
justice to prostitute those people
that all being said we uh inherited a
broken
system that was never set up to handle
anywhere near
the capacity that came in as a result of
the pandemic
uh we put people in there the system
crashed we fixed it it crashed we fixed
it it crashed
uh and we did what we can to deal with
people but those are skilled positions
that people need to be trained for in
order to evaluate claims
we're getting them out as fast as we
possibly can
uh it wasn't for unfortunate that it's
taken this long but
this is a common problem all over the
country i'm not making excuses for it
but i'm saying that we need to fix the
system
completely so that next time we run into
a situation where the system is strained
or put under the stress
it won't totally break down i'm gonna
assume you're running for re-election
when the time comes
i am okay uh sheriff lombardo clark
county as you know
and uh north las vegas mayor john lee
have come out i'm sure things will
change
you know them well you've been down here
you know how how that works
what keep what do you think are going to
be the key issues
years down the line for when your
reelection is
that might differentiate you from
whether it's mr lombardo mr lee or
whoever else might be uh
running yeah we've got two up north and
two down here so at least four people
have already said that they're running
i think what you're going to have to
look at is what some of these plans are
and what they've done it's easy to sit
back and be a monday morning quarterback
uh you know when you come to these
situations this state
faced a pandemic that if it comes once
in a century
uh is it's just amazing it was
devastating to our entire economy
we need to make some needed to make some
really really hard decisions
and i needed to stand my ground and put
in mind what was the absolute best
for all of the residents of the state of
nevada the 3.2 million people that call
nevada home
and i believe we did that and i think we
did it as best we possibly can
we're in a situation where we were
concerned about running out of body bags
that's how bad it was and how bad the
air quality could get
as it did in some areas from you know
the situation that we face it's just uh
it's very difficult to balance keeping
our
hospitals open and not over stressing
our health care system
at the same time not totally destroying
our economy
trying to keep people so that they could
pay their rent trying to keep people so
they get your food on the table
and do testing and stride up the vaccine
program we had a lot of balls in the air
at one time
and it was very very difficult to do i
think we made the best decisions we
could
based on the information that was
available at the time
and like i say it's uh i think we're
going to come out better we're going to
come out stronger
and we're going to come out uh with a
better economy and a better future
now we had a much longer interview than
that we have the full interview
available for you at 8newsnow.com we
also talk
more about the legislative session the
vaccine lottery as for sheriff joe
lombardo he makes his
official campaign announcement as a
republican for governor that'll be on
monday at rancho high
meanwhile former senator dean heller is
putting out feelers about his own run
for governor the republicans been
speaking to rural county republican
events with
other announced candidates he spoke in
elko june 12th
and acknowledged he is considering a run
heller also made an appearance up in
churchill county last month he's kept a
low profile since losing his senate seat
to democrat jackie rosen in 2018.
u.s secretary of labor marty walsh
visited las vegas this week
he pitched the bide administration's
american jobs plan
secretary walsh toured several local
unions including the culinary academy of
las vegas
former the former mayor of boston was
also part of a labor union before he
jumped into politics
he described the importance of
retraining people saying many
hospitality workers are learning new
skills because some industries are slow
to bounce back
and you think about convince incentive
businesses across the country um you
know
it's it's it's easy to shut it down
because it's you have to shut it down
it's harder to get it going it's like
kind of like an old engine getting it
cranked back up again
and but i do feel that you know
president biden is is
laser focused on getting our economy
going getting the economy cranking
walsh says recovering from a pandemic is
unlike recovering from a recession
people he says still have health
concerns and child care concerns
that have to be dealt with the federal
government is launching a new tool to
help you
file for the new child tax credit it's
part of president biden's american
rescue plan and gives families hundreds
of dollars per
child every month in order to qualify
you have to make seventy five thousand
dollars or less
if you're single or a hundred fifty
thousand dollars or less if you're
married
families with a child under six will get
three hundred dollars a month
families with children between 6 and 17
years old will get 250 dollars for each
child
democratic congressman stephen horsford
says more than 90 percent of families in
his district here in southern nevada are
eligible
i was listening uh to one of the parents
in my district
who has two young daughters you know
he's gonna make sure that one gets
their their eyeglasses and the other get
to go see the dentist
that's how parents are gonna use this
money is for the benefit of their kids
and to cover essential expenses
sometimes that's
very essential like housing and food and
in other cases it may be just being able
to do that little something extra
that they weren't able to do because
things have been tight for so many
families
if you did not file taxes this year you
can still claim the credit on the irs's
website
we have a link to that over at
eightnewsnow.com
a longtime unlv professor who was a
passionate and influential advocate for
growth here in southern nevada has
passed away
dr robert lang lost his battle with
cancer here's some video from
one of the many interviews he did with
us here on politics now and for eight
news now
dr lang was executive director of
brookings mountain west and the lindsey
institute over at unlv
he was one of the main policy analysts
behind the unlv school of medicine the
new one the corcoran school
a legion stadium and other major
projects in the valley dr
lang was 62 years old
coming up next here on politics now
looking at the next election
i know and appreciate your question but
i'm not going to touch that with a
10-foot poll
welcome back to politics now
elections and voting on the forefront of
the national conversation nevada and
other states are making changes to how
our elections work
but a recent monmouth poll found that
about a third of americans still think
joe biden won the 2020 election because
of voter fraud
the i-team's david charns spoke with
white house pest secretary jen saki
about that
and the possibility of nevada holding
the nation's first presidential primary
nevada was a state obviously that the
president carried in in 2020
um a state where our republican
secretary of state
found you know uh i can count the amount
of voter fraud
allegations on on you know two hands
however there are still people in this
state who believe
that the election was stolen uh what
does the president say about that kind
of
of kind of stuff when there are people
who with no evidence
seem to think that you know he's somehow
not the president what
what does he say you know that that we
don't see about this stuff
look i think the president's view is one
uh the facts are on his side
as you noted uh voter fraud is not a
widespread issue
across the country in nevada or in any
other state across the country
and a lot of these voter restriction
laws that some legislatures are pushing
forward
are based on what he considers and what
we consider the big lie
which is which is this notion that there
was fraud and what we know is that there
were dozens of court cases fought
over this uh and none of them overturned
the outcome of the election one that the
american people
voted for now he feels that the most
effective role he can play
is by governing for all people by
showing people that government can work
for them
that he doesn't look at getting the
pandemic under control putting people
back to work
making sure families have assistance
through a political prism
that's the role he can play but it is
something that
society is going to have to continue to
fight back against which is
false information and arguments about
voting fraud that aren't true
would the president like to see nevada
be the first in the nation primary state
i know and appreciate your question but
i'm not going to touch that with a
10-foot poll
uh or weigh in on the political order or
or presidential nominating process we're
pretty focused on
the job he's doing as president at least
she
knows and acknowledges the question back
to the drawing board coming up next on
politics now what's the next
step on election reform as it's stalled
in congress
plus a new nevada law that protects
hairstyle discrimination
at work this week senate republicans
stopped an election reform measure that
was being pushed by democrats
before the people act would have made
major changes to voting and election
efforts
it was a party-line vote 50-50 not to
proceed with debate on the measure
so that's 10 votes shy of the majority
required to move forward
democrats say this law would remove
hurdles to voting republicans say it's a
federal overreach
it is a solution in search of a problem
we will put an end to it here in the
senate
in response to donald trump's lies
republican state legislatures
immediately launched the most sweeping
voter suppression efforts
in at least 80 years the question is
what democrats will do next
a growing number of progressive groups
say it's time to change senate rules to
allow democrats to pass this
measure without republicans at least two
democrats
say though they're not on board with
that there's been a lot of heavy heavy
lobbying for and against that election
reform bill the most memorable
was in support of the measure featuring
katy perry and orlando bloom in a
dystopian future
are our only hope the america you know
doesn't exist in our future
democracy is dead we have no voice
the regime watches our every move it
started when voter suppression ran wild
all over america the voting rights bills
died in the senate so that was paid for
by a pac
called represent us in favor of the for
the people act
now we told you earlier about a national
monmouth poll about election related
issues this week
wanted to share a couple of other
opinions about laws being debated right
now
so people said they support national
guidelines allowing vote by mail
and in-person voting with 69 percent as
you see there in favor meanwhile
80 percent support requiring voters to
show photo id in order to vote
that was also 84 among non-white voters
this week president joe biden announced
a bipartisan deal with senators on an
infrastructure measure
the agreement mostly invests in
traditional infrastructure projects
across the country
as jessica explains top congressional
leaders
made it clear this is not a done deal
we have a deal a rare display of
bipartisanship on the white house
grounds thursday
as republicans and democrats and the
president agreed on a nearly one
trillion dollar infrastructure plan
to put people to work all across the
country the senate plan provides money
for everything from roads to high-speed
internet
to electric utilities there's going to
be a lot of jobs that come out of this
louisiana republican bill cassidy
stressed the agreement also protects
against extreme weather
investment and the resiliency that will
be essential
as we address our changing environment
the plan's lead negotiators ohio
republican rob portman
and arizona democrat kirsten cinema were
able to merge their two parties
priorities
we didn't get everything we wanted but
we came up with a good compromise
we all gave some to get some the group
landed on pay fors that include unused
covet 19 relief funds
and 580 billion dollars in new revenue
from things like tax law enforcement
and customs user fees without raising a
cent
from earners below four hundred thousand
dollars
but the deal comes with strings attached
the president and house speaker nancy
pelosi
say democrats will also forge ahead with
plans to pass a larger bill
it would address human infrastructure
like child care and education
using a procedure called reconciliation
there ain't
going to be an infrastructure bill
unless we have the reconciliation bill
that bigger bill can pass without
republican support
if every senate democrat votes yes
jessie noor reporting there next on
politics now ending discrimination how a
nevada law will protect women's
hairstyle choices
you're watching politics now
hair-based discrimination is now illegal
in nevada
governor steve sisilak signed the crown
act into law this month
it stands for creating a respectful and
open world for natural hair
bianca holman explains the impact of
this new legislation
hair is a form of expression identity
and a connection to heritage
especially in the black community for me
hair is an accessory you should be able
to wear it how you want
it's beautiful though it's a very like
night and day type of thing if it's wet
the shrinkage is in one way when it's
blow-dried it's another way
for many black women there's a shared
experience growing up
memories of straightening coily and
curly hair through the use of chemicals
or heat
often times in order to fit a european
beauty standard
yindra dixon who works in a professional
setting says she was met with comments
from former co-workers during her hair
journey definitely microaggressions can
i touch it
um you know what did you do you know
when uh when black women put in braids
all of a sudden it's like oh my gosh you
know what happened to your hair
because it has transitioned into
something completely different black
women are 80 percent more likely to have
changed their hair from its natural
state to fit into the office
and they're also one and a half times
more likely to be sent home from work
because of their hair that's according
to the 2019 dove
crown research study professional
stylists say the pressure to conform
is damaging and we're stylists we don't
want to straighten that much we'll tell
you like
don't put that much heat on your hair
it's going to damage your hair you're
going to lose your hair
senators dina neal and dallas harris
pushed for the crown
act protecting those who wear hair
styles like braids
locks and twists people lack education
when it comes to hair
we are typically judged based off
how our hair looks people who don't
understand
maybe have only had the influences of
their families they take
those biases into the workplace the
crown act
is life-changing i think it's super
important i think it's amazing
as we break the chains of slavery as we
liberate ourselves
as a people as we liberate ourselves as
a community and as we work with our
allies to bring equity and justice
to um to our community it is imperative
that we let black women be free that we
let them do what they want with their
hair bianca holman
8 news now we have a statement from
state senator dina neal
on the passing of the crown act over at
eight newsnow dot com
that'll do it for politics now this week
we thank you very much for joining us
and we'll see you back here on saturday